face au pack surpuissant de boer points
emmené par schabowski et bien sûr
l'international cécillon lui s rement
comptait sur la solidarité de son équipe
et notamment les arrières parmi eux un
trois-quarts est classé dans les
meilleurs marqueurs d'essais du
championnat le 9 septembre
on dit que je brille parce que j'ai
marqué six essais classement mais c'est
grâce à l'équipe et surtout parce qu'on
soit régna l'on joue un ballon quand je
joue au rugby ou en attaque
et là c'est sûr que quand bourgoin où ça
va être un match un peu de la match
régional et on va essayer de faire un
grand spectacle pour le public
on vous en planter un aujourd'hui j'ai
essayé chez scellé la marque et j'espère
surtout que pour le public ce sera très
beau et qui aura pas que des coups de
pied qui aura de belles attaques et des
belles envolées le talent
permettent un roman de réussir le mac
sur notre bourgoin alors que le gardien
avait mené 12 à 3 un résultat plutôt
flatteur pour bourgoin carcéraux mon
pied a fait l'essentiel du jeu il
conclut un pouce
les berjalliens pouvant s'estimer
heureux d'inscrire cet essai
d'interception par l'intermédiaire
broche les autres points ont été marqués
sur pénalités et transformations décès
l'arrière de bourgoin l'ex commissaire a
été plus heureux que son avis romanet
darley celui ci échoue sur une pénalité
facile
en tout les menaces dommage pour roman
qui méritait de gagner ce derby
reste que l'équipe drômoise affiche de
réels progrès et on lui souhaite garder
ses meilleurs éléments
on se relance mon club je joue depuis
poussins et c'est donc là que j'ai
commencé et là je joue en équipe
première c'est un rêve de gamin si je
peux jouer plus haut
pourquoi pas sentez bien ici ou quoi
pour l'instant oui mais on ne sait
jamais